you created something super special with
that first movie and I feel like when it
comes to the miniseries and maybe even
the book for some people out there it's
always the part with the kids that has
that special spark so I'm curious how
did you go about creating it with the
second movie is there anything you and
Gary would say that was our break story
moment it's important to me to generate
that you know that that that engagement
with with the losers at this period in
life you know it's a new cast same
characters but new cast so for me part
part of the function of the old oats
like member flashbacks in the movie is
you know generating that the tunnel
between the two with the two timelines
of a of each character to ease that you
know emotional connection of the
audience have your phenomenal phenomenal
cast but you know the truth is that
people know the losers from a - and
they're you know they love these kids so
but now they they would love the adults
I certainly already do I also wanted to
ask about the scene that Stephen King
told you to add to it because if I hear
that Stephen King of all people added a
scene to this movie that thrills me to
no end so I'm curious which one was it
that's not true he's unfortunate no it's
a broken you know like communication
Steve I love this man and and he's been
so supportive of this no I just like
share the script with him and I because
I wanted to know you know what he
thought about it his you know he has any
kind of note and he very you know very
very generously said look this is not
don't take it just take this as what it
is this is not a mandate or anything but
this is like the couple of things that I
would like to see in the movie and and
that's that's what it was can you share
any particular notes hiki no no yes I
can now all of Stephen King secrets he
wanted to you know he they're worth
that were already on their way to land
in the movie he will he was you know
he's a fan of Paul Bunyan and Paul
Bunyan and especially specifically
probing and chasing young Richie so that
was great because you know I was a
little bit under on the on the fence
with that and when Steve said and I put
it in the MOOC and if we scan we see it
in the boys like yes of course and the
other one was the the rolling standpipe
at the end of you know in the book when
Derry collapses into the sinkhole and it
all floods there is a scene there where
the standpipe basically collapses and
starts rolling down the hill and for
some reason is one of Steven's favorite
like episodes in the pen the book and
it's funny actually there's like it
seemed like the whole episode was seen
by a by a guy that is like you know
smoking a spliff and it's looking at
it's like he says something like he'd
that's Steven Spielberg something like
that because of the scope of a scene
well we couldn't go that far because I
would you know I basically wanted to and
the movie in a more emotional note more
intimate more and more about the
feelings of of this group of characters
and also like making this like huge you
know destruction scene would have sucked
probably have a budget of visual effects
I didn't go I don't want to go through
that yeah speaking of the visual effects
here you have such a great mixture of
visual effects and also practical
effects - so I'm curious was there any
particular scene in this movie where you
were wavering which way to go with a
certain scare I normally go practical
until you know practical reaches that
you know that boundary of of credibility
mm-hm and you know I grew up in the 80s
so I have you know I have a
like I have a weakness for practical
effects but there's a point where you
just have to enhance it with with
digital and and you know anyways it's
also I mean it is a shape-shifter a
shape-shifting creature who inevitably
you know there is a point where we want
to see like do something that cannot be
done practical and and that's why when I
opened my arms to CG you know there's
like a lot of prejudice with CG but it's
like the truth is that CT has reached
depending on who you work with how
sophisticated the design is you know a
surrealistic is as opposed to something
that is like you know conventional and
and familiar to to the audience I'm on
the weird side so the more weird and and
you know and and so realistic that
design is the more you're basically
distracting the audience from the fact
that that is the CG and really to be
honest the level of detail and the net
level of accuracy that these houses are
reaching is amazing creature wise you
know absolutely have like a level of
detail on the close-ups and everything
that there's like I mean I really
challenged people to to say that is CG
that is not of course you will see
impossible things like in the first
movie like penny wise you know
corkscrewing out of the of the of the
fridge there's no way to say that is CG
by looking at the texture and the light
and the whole ringing but it's
impossible for someone to do it that's
why that's why some you know I'm a
believer that anything is possible
yeah it's yeah